francia vive hoy una inmigración sin
precedentes actualmente hay 7 millones
de inmigrantes el 10 3 por ciento de la
población total la cifra más alta el
número y porcentaje de la población que
el país ha registrado que proponen los
candidatos para enfrentar este desafío
referéndum 10 de los 12 candidatos
quieren hacer esta consulta sobre los
temas clave del país incluida la
migración pero dos se focalizan en el
tema tanto marín depende el partido
reagrupación nacional como erick zemmour
del partido la reconquista ambos de
extrema derecha proponen un referendo
para ponerle fin al reagrupamiento
familiar y al derecho europeo por encima
del francés además de endurecer el
acceso a la nacionalidad reformular el
control de las fronteras y la creación
por parte de ese muro del ministerio de
la re migración para expulsar a un
millón de extranjeros derecho de asilo
todos los candidatos quieren
garantizarlo pero con ajustes el
presidente candidato de manuel macro de
la república en marcha quiere facilitar
la expulsión de las personas a las que
se les haya negado asilo y mantener las
cuotas de inmigrantes una reforma en su
mandato que para muchos fue un giro a la
derecha de su política migratoria
lepe en ese muro y la candidata
conservadora valérie pécresse de los
republicanos quieren que todas las
solicitudes se hagan desde el exterior
la expulsión de condenados extranjeros 5
de los 12 candidatos manifiestan en sus
programas estar de acuerdo con la
expulsión de delincuentes extranjeros de
pene pécresse macro ni se murió este
último propone expulsar también a los
fichados como radicales islamistas lucha
contra el islam radical y el terrorismo
macro mantiene la idea del cierre de
asociaciones y mezquitas radicales y en
firme la llamada ley contra el
separatismo aprobada en su quinquenio la
misma que quiere derogar el candidato de
izquierda a jean luc mélenchon de la
francia insumisa por considerarla anti
republicana y tildada por le ven como
insuficiente ella prohibirá de raíz la
práctica y la difusión pública de la
ideología islamista
quienes entran a francia y quienes no un
desafío en las propuestas de los
candidatos que tratan de responder a
este fenómeno migratorio al que ahora se
suma la ola de refugiados ucranianos